Miriam was testing her null hypothesis
that the population mean of some dataset
is equal to 18 versus her alternative
hypothesis is that the mean is less than
18 with a sample of 7 observations her
test statistic I can never say that was
T is equal to negative 1.9 assume that
the conditions for inference were met
what is the approximate p-value for
Miriam's test so pause this video and
see if you can figure this out on your
own all right well I always just like to
remind ourselves what's going on here
before I just go ahead and calculate the
p-value so there's some data set some
population here and the null hypothesis
is that the true mean is 18 the
alternative is that it's less than 18 so
to test that null hypothesis Miriam
takes a sample sample size is equal to 7
from that she would calculate her sample
mean and her sample standard deviation
and from that she would calculate this T
statistic the way she would do that or
if they didn't tell us ahead of time
what that was they'd say okay well we'd
say the T statistic is equal to her
sample mean minus the assumed mean from
the null hypothesis that's what we have
over here divided by and this is a
mouthful our approximation of the
standard error of the mean and the way
we get that approximation we take our
sample standard deviation and divide it
by the square root of our sample size
well they've calculated this ahead of
time for us this is equal to negative
1.9 and so if we think about a T
distribution
I'll try to hand draw a rough T
distribution really fast and if this is
the mean of the T distribution what we
are curious about because our
alternative hypothesis is that the mean
is less than 18 so what we care about is
well what is the probability of getting
a t-value that is more than 1.9 below
the mean so this right over here
negative 1.9 so it's this area right
there and so I'm going to do this with a
ti-84 at least an emulator of a ti-84
and all we have to do is we would go to
second distribution and then I would use
the T cumulative distribution function
so let's go there that's the number six
right there click enter and so my lower
bound yeah I essentially wanted to be
negative infinity and so we can just
call that negative infinity is just
approximation of negative infinity very
very low number our upper bound would be
negative one point nine negative one
point nine and then our degrees of
freedom that's our sample size minus one
our sample size is seven so our degrees
of freedom would be six and so there we
have it and then so this would be our
p-value would be approximately zero
point zero five three so our p-value
would be approximately zero point zero
five three and then what Myriam would do
is would compare this p-value to her
preset significance level two alpha if
this is below alpha then she would
reject her null hypothesis which would
suggest the alternative if this is above
alpha then she would fail to reject her
null hypothesis